cerchiamo persone
simili dove testa
simili un po di flessibilità per favore
abbiamo trovato un ragazzo per il
magazzino che nonostante abbia accettato
un contratto a tempo determinato si
tratta di lavorare anche nei weekend non
fa nessun problema è molto flessibile e
soprattutto è un gran lavoratore in
guida galattica per autostoppisti questo
libro è questo film divenuti oggetto di
culto per moltissimi smanettoni in tutto
il mondo
il supercomputer interpellato per
rispondere alle domande sull'universo la
vita e tutto il resto ci mette 7 milioni
di anni per trovare la risposta a una
domanda che nessuno si ricorda più
quello di cui io voglio parlare oggi
sono proprio le risposte che noi
riceviamo a domande che non abbiamo mai
fatto
cosa che in pubblicità ormai succede
quasi da 50 ne era un dentifricio molto
famoso che aveva questo slogan ti spunta
un fiore in bocca
sì ma la domanda qual era
o così o pomì anche qui una bella
dichiarazione di intenti ma la domanda
non era neanche prevista bei tempi
quelli in cui anche le domande di noi
recruiter erano così interessanti come
si vede fra i dieci anni un po più
vecchio ma è esposta una volta un
candidato quelle domande in cui punti di
debolezza straordinariamente coincidono
con i punti di forza un suo punto di
debolezza sono troppo sensibile
oppure perché dovremmo scegliere lei
perché mia moglie a tutti i costi vuole
che io mi trovi un lavoro per fortuna ci
sono un po di colleghi che hanno deciso
di inserire nelle domande per i colloqui
un poligami fiction che è quel quella
parola che si utilizza nelle risorse
umane a conferma della totale
incapacità di dare qualcosa di sensato a
un pò di innovazione chi vincerebbe in
un combattimento fra superman e batman
come farebbe a far stare un elefante in
un frigorifero come si comporterebbe se
fosse l'unico sopravvissuto a un
disastro aereo ecco io non credo che
queste domande qui mi aiuteranno mai a
trovare un bravo commerciale ma di
sicura riempiranno di allegri a quelle
ore in cui sono costretto a subire dei
colloqui molto pallosi ma le domande
serie sono quelle che avrebbero dovuto
fare certi giornali e certi giornalisti
quando l'associazione di categoria degli
imprenditori già nel 2015 aveva
dichiarato che è introvabile un
lavoratore su cinque nel 2016 poi hanno
dichiarato che le tecnologie avrebbero
creato disoccupazione nel 2016
addirittura che mancano all'appello più
di 200 mila profili professionali e la
vera domanda quella che non avete fatto
è stato ma come li avete cercate queste
persone ma avete le competenze per
trovare le risorse che visse che vi
servono e soprattutto conoscete gli
strumenti più adeguati per trovare
queste persone no perché io un po di
ricerca l'ho fatta ho trovato che
proprio il responsabile del personale
della suddetta associazione di categoria
nel 2017 aveva solo inc ed in tre
connessioni e neanche la foto sul
profilo probabilmente deve essere venuto
a qualche mio intervento forse ha
comprato dei follower perché nel 2019
d'incanto arrivano 400 contatti e anche
una bella foto smagliante sul profilo
sono ancora pochi ma ci sono le buone
speranze peggio quegli imprenditori che
da due anni si fanno pubblicità gratuita
sui giornali dichiarando che i giovani
non vogliono lavorare
valeria 34 anni tre figli
una mattina va proprio in quel famoso
panificio milanese e il giorno stesso
incomincia a lavorare
scoprendo che non sono i giovani che non
hanno voglia di lavorare ma che è
quell'imprenditore non aveva sfogliato
neanche uno delle decine di curriculum
che erano arrivati quest'estate a
gabicce il sindaco lancia l'allarme
mancano gli operatori per
per la riviera per il turismo in riviera
nello stesso tempo il sindacato riceve
decine di segnalazione da parte di
lavoratori sottopagati prevalentemente
stranieri ai quali non solo vengono
negati i diritti fondamentali ma non
viene assicurato neanche l'alloggio e i
pasti che per un lavoratore stagionale
sono il minimo sindacale per fortuna ci
sono delle buone notizie ci sono delle
aziende che dal profondo nord arrivano
nel laborioso sud a reclutare neo
diplomati e neo laureati per contaminare
tanto la cultura aziendale quanto per
importare o nuovi approcci nuove
competenze e nuove conoscenze
non ci dimentichiamo che milano è la
seconda città pugliese d'italia ma la
vera domanda è le macchine ci ruberanno
posti di lavoro ecco mi piacerebbe
rispondere con le parole di un ingegnere
e un ex ingegnere dell'ibm per molti di
noi conosciuto meglio come scrittore ho
come filosofo e tanti di noi lo hanno
amato veramente luciano de crescenzo che
a questa domanda ha risposto le macchine
ci sostituiranno quando saranno in grado
di capire l'ironia
certo se non bastasse rimaniamo in
ingegneria un altro ingegnere ha sempre
dell'ibm esperto di block chain e cripto
valute si chiama massimo chiriatti ha
scritto questo libro meraviglioso e
anche lui da una risposta
l'algoritmo ci toglie dalle mani milioni
di mansioni ma inconsapevolmente ci dà
un vantaggio
le macchine sono tutte uguali tra loro
sono fungibili possono essere inter
cambiate
noi invece possiamo mettere in campo
uomini e donne che hanno una grande
qualità sono creativi e non sono
prevedibili
una recente ricerca di deloitte dove
sono stati intervistati centinaia di
direttore del personale in giro per il
mondo sugli asset intangibili delle
aziende parlando di selezione del
personale tecnologie è risultato che il
16 per cento degli intervistati ricky e
ritiene che questa che la selezione del
personale debba essere un processo da
rivedere nel 2019
altri ritengono che meglio solo il 4 per
cento ritiene che questi siano processi
di recruiting e funzionale
cioè nelle aziende i direttori del
personale non credono ai loro processi
talent mobility e un po quel quel
progetto e quel processo per il quale
una persona all'interno della stessa
azienda può cambiare posto di lavoro può
fare delle funzioni diverse
sembra che la 86 per cento dei
dipendenti non sappia quali sono le
posizioni aperte nella propria azienda
questo significa non solo che non stiamo
valorizzando le nostre risorse non
stiamo motivando ai nostri collaboratori
non li conosciamo ma che stiamo
spendendo soldi tanti più soldi per
portare in casa competenze da fuori che
probabilmente già abbiamo al nostro
interno
e quanto bello sarebbe nell'anno in cui
la parola più importante e sostenibilità
se ci fossero molte meno macchine che
tutte le mattine si spostano da casa per
raggiungere un posto di lavoro
quanto più ambiente ci sarebbe ma
soprattutto come lavorerebbero meglio
quei padri e quelle madri che possono
accompagnare i loro figli a scuola senza
avere l'incubo dell'orario e del
cartellino
la formazione è uno degli asset
fondamentali per quanto riguarda le
aziende
peccato che la 86 per cento ritiene che
bisogna reinventare la formazione non è
sufficiente quello che noi abbiamo è
soltanto il 16 per cento si ritiene
pronto questo cambiamento
userei le parole di alvin toffler che è
un saggista statunitense che ama
definirsi futurologo non a caso lui dice
che gli analfabeti le xxi secolo non
saranno quelli che non sanno leggere e
scrivere ma saranno quelli che non sanno
imparare disimparare air imparare di
nuovo
attenzione perché la formazione sta
vivendo un momento di straordinario
impulso non tanto dovuto alle macchine
alle tecnologie ma proprio al fattore
umano cioè per la prima volta nella
nostra epoca
noi stiamo avendo insieme due
generazioni a confronto abbiamo il
signor che come sempre possono
condividere competenze conoscenze di
settore ma soprattutto possono
trasmettere tutti quegli errori che non
vanno rifatti perché sono stati già
commessi dagli altri ma soprattutto
nello stesso tempo noi abbiamo
che possono insegnare ai piu anziani
l'utilizzo di nuove tecnologie e un
nuovo modo di lavorare più agile più
veloce è invece il rischio quale è
quello che stiamo dividendo queste
generazioni non ne stiamo facendo
dialogare fra di loro
non stiamo creando quel punto di
contatto e con la semplificazione con
cui noi siamo sempre molto molto capaci
rischiamo spesso di definire questa una
generazione arrogante semplicemente
perché una generazione più veloce che
brucia le tappe che non segue gli schemi
ma non è che per caso invece è un
discorso semplicemente di valori diversi
sono cambiati i valori forse proprio su
questo che dobbiamo lavorare con questi
ragazzi
dobbiamo fargli capire un po meglio
certi valori legati al lavoro
soprattutto capire che l'innovazione non
è l'alibi di certe multinazionali con
cui si azzerano le dignità delle persone
e del lavoro spiegare loro che tutele e
doveri sono parte della stessa medaglia
sono due parole che appartengono al
lavoro adesso c'è stata questa tavola
rotonda degli amministratori delegati
delle aziende più importanti del mondo
per una volta si è detto che il padrone
delle aziende non è più il fatturato ma
che bisogna incominciare a ridistribuire
il valore tanto agli investitori quanto
alle persone quanto all'ambiente
bisogna iniziare a dare uno scopo alle
azioni bisogna dichiarare lo scopo degli
obiettivi le nuove generazioni alle
nuove generazioni non basta più sapere
dove devono raggiungere un risultato ma
perché devono raggiungere quel risultato
peccato che neanche il giorno dopo forse
magari ci fosse stata un po più di
coerenza vicino alle parole ci sarebbe
piaciuto perché la multinazionale
johnson and johnson è stata condannata a
pagare 572 milioni di dollari per aver
contribuito a creare la crisi dei
farmaci antidolorifici che ogni giorno
secondo il governo federale uccide 130
persone
il discorso qual è che lo stato
dell'oklahoma aveva chiesto 17 miliardi
gli analisti di wall street se ne
aspettavano 25 172 milioni sono stati
salutati dalle borse con un più 2 per
cento e quindi quando michela mazzucco
professoressa italiana e una delle
università più importanti della francia
ci dice che probabilmente noi stiamo
vendendo l'etica così come si fa
pubblicità forse ha ragione forse la
responsabilità sociale d'impresa è
soltanto un oggetto di pubblicità e
comunicazione per fortuna loro loeb i
corpi italiane che hanno comprato subito
dopo quella tavola rotonda due pagine
sui maggiori giornali italiani per dire
attenzione perché noi lo stiamo già
facendo nel nostro statuto c'è scritto
che il fatturato si però tanta
ridistribuzione alle nostre persone
nostri territori tanto valore in più e
allora riprendiamoci un po le parole
affidiamoci di più alla curiosità quella
curiosità che fa sì che non accettiamo
risposte se non abbiamo fatto domande
quella curiosità che ci permette di
rispondere nei post sui social network
non solo avendo letto un titolo e
soprattutto di non sostituire i titoli
con degli hashtag che sono stai violenti
che sono astag che ipotecano la vita
delle persone
la curiosità è quella cosa che ha fatto
sì che una persona come emilio salgari
che non ha mai viaggiato in vita sua il
cui viaggio più lungo è stato fra
pescara ed ancona abbia scritto dei
libri straordinari soltanto
intervistando persone che venivano da
quei luoghi e che avevano visto quegli
animali e quelle cose e che hanno fatto
sognare i bambini di tantissime
generazioni
le parole del lavoro sono importanti
pensate che cosa può aver provato quella
professoressa siciliana che si è trovata
a sospesa
semplicemente perché dicono che non
abbia supervisionato il lavoro dei suoi
studenti che avevano paragonato le leggi
razziali del 35 al decreto sicurezza
i suoi studenti al suo rientro l'hanno
accolta con 15 rosa e rosso e infine
torniamo al nostro amico flessibile
avrete capito che mi piacciono le
domande mi piacciono anche le parole del
lavoro flessibile e questo non può
essere una persona così come le persone
non possono essere risorse umane ed è
per questo che da un po di tempo
io le chiamo umane risorse perché
soltanto invertendo le prospettive si
possono cambiare finali delle storie
delle persone
grazie